right it's time for third and short
three quick ones for you baltimore team
that's back on track probably even more
than back on track the chargers were
just red hot and they whooped on them
what's impressed you most there with
baltimore ravens
they're playing tremendous team football
and it starts with lamar jackson lamar
jackson everybody's criticizing him
saying that he can't be a great passer
he can be a great passer and what i see
in him what i'm starting to see is that
he's starting to read and understand
what nfl defenses are doing to him
sitting back holding the linebacker
seeing exactly what they're trying to do
a cover three zone he looks over to the
flare route he holds a linebacker and he
completes it to mark andrews this is
what they do but also getting back to
what they do defensively showing
different looks pressure corners
safeties everybody up there confusing
justin herbert and he has no idea he's a
really good quarterback he has no idea
but also sending a message saying look
we're going to run at your very best
player you see bosa number 65 just
putting them on his back we're going to
send a message we're running directly at
your best player your 100 million dollar
guy we're coming right at him with our
right tackle we're going to double team
them and we're going to clear them out
the way so chargers if you have a
problem with your defense now you see it
doesn't matter who they put there
whether it's bolsa you guys are getting
blown off the ball but that's why the
ravens are so good because they're
getting it done in different aspects and
it starts with lamar
it's a scary thought thinking about how
much better he's gotten from the pocket
as a passer
just because this running game even when
teams knew they were going to run the
ball they can't do anything about it and
i think you just have to give love to
this offensive line who is playing
without ronnie stanley who now is going
to miss the rest of the season he's got
to get ankle surgery again so now you're
going to play the whole year without
ronnie stanley i just think villanueva
powers bozeman up there zeitler as well
so i just think this whole group and
what they've been able to piece together
without their big money guy and ronnie
stanley has been really impressive
hollywood brown continues to play
like a receiver who's developing into a
really really good one uh and lamar
jackson throwing it around like this
with mark andrews as well helps like
this team right now is playing
unbelievable football and everybody's so
high on the chargers the chargers have
beat the chiefs they beat the browns
gone toe-to-toe with some of the best
and baltimore just went in there and
made this look like the old chargers
team you got to be thinking man
this right here might be a team looking
to win a super bowl and this means
something to lamar jackson because you
can tell by how improved he's been
throwing the football
one big blow one big blow to the ravens
i heard today that ronnie stanley he's
going to be out he's going to be out for
the rest of the year hurt his ankle he's
going to be out so that's a significant
blow 100 got 100 million dollar guy and
they're um
starting all pro left tackle one kid
that really impressed me i'm gonna be
quick with this rashad bateman when i
was with harbaugh he told me he said
rodney watch out for this kid he's gonna
be an excellent football player he's
gonna make a difference and you see it
you see the quickness you see the route
running you see the soft hands you see
it and he's only going to continue and
approve you add him with marquis brown
mark andrews and that run game and i
agree with you you know what i've been
actually kind of sleeping on the ravens
a little bit i've kind of been taking
them for granted but you're right if
they can continue this defense is only
going to continue to improve and this is
a defense that's been just been
absolutely obliterated um at the in the
secondary with injuries but yeah if they
can keep they can keep going which i
know they will they can be right there
in the um super bowl conversation with
buffalo in kansas city i'm with you
let's get to another team that's in that
super bowl conversation they're similar
to buffalo that's a good point and that
they're just so sick of hearing about it
you know what i mean to me those are two
teams at the top of the list the ravens
and the bills they are just so sick of
hearing about that they are a tier below
and they're ready to prove that they're
not and i think you're seeing it on the
field with both those two teams let's
get to the cardinals though talent all
over the field with this unit why are
you believing what's being built there
with arizona
well i mean it's one thing to have
talent and we've i've always played
against the raiders that had a bunch of
first round draft choice we've always
seen the cowboys with talent it's one
thing to have talent but the thing that
stands out to me is when you watch those
guys play they play hard they play with
passion they play for one another i was
watching tape and you see j.j watt you
see j.j watt i mean look at the effort
of number heat number 99 he's getting
double team and he's still working and
he comes off and gets a strip sack
that's the guy that's been a three-time
defensive player of the year showing all
that effort look at him everybody else
is standing around j.j watt he's made
hundreds of millions of dollars and he's
still but look at isaiah simmons isaiah
simmons
just watch the effort of number nine
look at the athletic skill that is a
wide receiver that he's chasing down and
look at everybody look at the excitement
look at everybody flooring the
misdirection play but look at this this
is a 6'4 235 pound
linebacker chasing down a wide receiver
but look at the effort it doesn't matter
if you are a second year player isaiah
simmons a top 10 pig or if you're j.j
watt who's been a three-time defensive
player of the year in his 30s these guys
are playing with tremendous effort and
that's the reason why they're undefeated
right now it was it was just so good to
watch
it is man it's awesome to watch and then
you think about that chandler jones
wasn't even playing in that game so when
chandler jones comes back and cliff
kingsbury their play caller and head
coach was not even on the field because
he had a positive test as well so you
reinsert two key pieces like that back
and without all of it kyler throws four
touchdowns to those three stars he's got
on the outside kirk green and deandre
hopkins those might be three receivers
that are as good of any group any
receiver core in the whole nfl go ahead
rod
one guy i haven't been able to mention i
have to mention him as byron murphy jr
he is playing on an all pro level um
diggs and byron murphy jr those guys
have been playing outstanding football
just as a note
they definitely have okay derek henry
speaking of outstanding football this
man right now is on pace for 2218
yards
783 yards and 10 touchdowns he has we're
only through six weeks of the season
does he go back to back 2000 yard
seasons like what do you think how does
this end with derek henry this year the
start's been off the chart
you know what man i would love to see
him get 2 000 yards and i think he has a
great chance i mean you just can't have
those games where you get 50 yards and
40 yards if you have a down game it has
to be at least 70 to 80 yards but i
believe in their criminary i think they
if they want to have success they're
definitely going to have to do this i
mean look at that that was mario addison
he's 285 pounds and he just he gives him
a stiff arm like get out of here you're
like a little boy to me and that's a big
grown man right there but look at him
one cut downhill no wasted steps running
over to safety this is what derek henry
does and i'm so grateful that i don't
have to hit a guy like this even though
he reminds me of brandon jacobs but this
is not even fair i think derek henry
will get 2 000 yards and if he gets 2
000 yards he is the mvp of this league
i kind of think he is assuming he can
stay healthy i'm knocking on wood right
now for him but with with aj brown and
with julio jones on the outside and the
way tana hill's playing i don't think
you can sell out to stop the run game
and that's his last five games i mean he
is going off right now so i think he
will have running lanes given that you
have to respect this passing game
because there is legitimate talent on
the outside for tennessee
listen i'm not respecting the passing
game
i have respect for it but i'm not
respected my number one goal if i'm i'm
a eight man in a box and even when you
have eight men in a box it's no
guarantee i'm trying to put nine guys in
a box my number one priority when i'm
playing against the tennessee titans is
tackle derek henry don't allow him to
get going i don't care about aj brown i
don't care about julio jones those two
guys have to prove to me that they can
stay healthy
and
i'm not afraid of them i'm afraid of
derrick henry so i'm trying to go on in
i'm trying to stop the run
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports